hello christine good morning thank you
for talking to me about this i had so
much fun i was just telling kate that
this movie just sort of fulfills all of
my childhood dance production fantasies
in every way so
it was so much fun
oh how delightful well i had so much fun
making it so thank you very much i'm
really pleased to hear that uh you know
kay cannon did such a great job in
embroidering such a story and taking a
story which is really a very ancient
story before disney there was cinderella
and it was
really a
story of repression
and uh to to find this wonderful actress
singer
entertainer in
camilla
is just was joyful to watch
uh so
yeah it's uh and then to hear the
reaction here this morning from from the
members of the press and uh
it's really heartwarming i saw it there
last week with my granddaughter who's
six
and uh she loved it
that's what
matters he's just beginning to figure
out that grandpa is you know in the
movies
what was it like for you when somebody
approaches you about playing a king in
cinderella i mean what was the initial
reaction to that
well i you know i i'm an actor and uh
i've i've
been
asked to play many roles and there's
always a kind of surprise factor i was i
was flattered uh
because the script was so good and the
company of actors the ensemble was so so
rich from billy porter as the fairy
godmother and eden menzel who is a
powerhouse of broadway
uh beaver
performer
and then of course minnie driver who
plays the queen she and i are all pals
and that was a delight
so i i i felt very comfortable i felt
confident and it allowed me to go back
to london
and
i love being able to go back to london
because i have
family there and friends
and kay just was so effervescent she
brought such a passion
to to to to each day's work
uh we started last year in february and
then came the covid
and it came in slowly slowly slowly and
this week we were up in blackpool doing
the uh the ballroom sequence there
there's a magnificent ballroom in
blackpool
and uh
on the friday they said that's it we're
closing down
and i hightailed it back here to
the north shore of kauai
and i thought that was it i thought well
that's over but five months later we
went back and uh
thank god we did and we went back under
the restrictions of covert you get
tested every day
and um you wear masks you take the masks
off you do the scene you sing sing sing
put the mask back on
so a challenge
and um
but
you know this this story as i say
cinderella is a very very ancient story
and but in the hands of kay and the
company the writers they really have
created something which is empowering
and beautiful and
exhilarating for young women
uh
young people
don't anyone you know
[Music]
and i think it's it's seamlessly
embroidered with the songs
that are familiar by great stars by
great singers
and you don't quite catch it and then
you go oh my god that was madonna or
that was queen
and so it's it's a compliment that you
know the narrative flowed into the song
so so effortlessly
how did you feel about your king's style
from his wardrobe to his crown to
the very specific facial hair that he
had were there conversations about
the look
in its entirety
there was
there was a little bit of a hiccup with
the beard i grew the beard and i wanted
to have a beard and i wanted to have
this
kind of
you know elegant
dartanian like beard and the studio
didn't like it well i liked it and i
just
we had a little backwards and forwards
and the beard stayed
so i just thought it very appropriate
that he should have a beard
and
you know on looking at all my
art documentaries on kings
there were beards
so
the costumes uh
well that
the costumes were magnificent
yeah uh really beautifully beautifully
founded each one was just a revelation
every day you go to work and
someone would be in this magnificent
costume
and um what else
what was it like to wear the crown i
mean does it do you feel different when
you have to put a crown on
um
not really it was a very beautiful crown
actually i woke up the other day and i
thought what happened to the crown i was
going to keep the crowd
maybe i could still get the crown from
the company but
highly unlikely
uh well there's such a flamboyance and
again the
the costumes give you such a regal
posture and elegance and
so the work the work came
effortlessly really
because of
k
uh k cannon and because of the ensemble
of actors they all played with such
you know they make you real when you're
working with good actors and good
sincerity and passion and spontaneity
all you have to do is sit back and react
and listen
say your lines clearly and simply
get off the stage without bumping into
the furniture
i love the scene that you have when you
ride up on the horse and you're in the
armor and you're you know singing and
sort of professing your love to minnie
driver's character
was it fun to have a little bit of humor
like that as well and to have him not be
so perfect and not be able to get off
the horse so well or deal with the armor
so well
well we did i asked for a song i said
come on kay you know you've you've seen
my work you know
you know you've seen the magnificent
voice of mamma mia i mean just
that alone
you know we're shortchanging ourselves
and the world by not having me sing
anyway she gets the joke i got the joke
and so she came up with this ridiculous
kind of acapella
nonsense song
you know
because he's such a
you know
egocentric narcissistic silly king and
it's all about him really wanting to
kill the sea monster and
wed his son to the next door
neighbor of royalty and so he can get
the land and
consequently
you know just
hurts his wife really
really just
he's not very pleasant
and so she banishes him from the bedroom
and
that's how that scene came about
nights and shining armor
trying to
get off the halls
and uh there's a nice bit in it when i
looked at it when i was singing to
minnie a fly
comes into the shot
so it was it was a nice little one of
those moments
things you have no control over
no no control over
could you ever have imagined at any
point in your career that you'd be
playing this king singing and dancing
and and you know sort of singing along
to a jennifer lopez song
yes absolutely 100
that's why i'm an actor
you do everything you want to play kings
and
you want to play queens
you want to play everything you know i
was i i went to a drama academy which
was very method orientated and i was led
to believe that i could play anything
and i
you know i i played many great roles
and then you know there were times when
i went to the board to see who i was
playing thinking i was going to be
the lead and i'd looked down the list
and i was playing the waiter
i was playing
i was playing the
messenger
but how do you play the messenger and
how do you still have
you know so you you
you carry with that within your heart as
an actor you know you can't
you you want to be a leading man all
your life but
there comes a time to just move over and
get on with the character work and
at this point in my my life you know i'm
in rel
reveling in playing
you know
the king and cinderella or
will farrell's father in eurovision or
dr fate and black adam
so
it's all going to plan
at uh at the time that you were james
bond that was really sort of the height
of action films and now there's this
whole world of comic book and superhero
movies and you know you've mentioned
being a part of that with black adam
what was it about that project that made
you want to be a part of that world and
what's it like to be in a big action
movie like that now
it's exhilarating
i had the most magnificent time in
with uh
jama colette sarah who's the director of
black adam
and uh
the most recent film with with dwayne
johnson um
jungle cruz uncle cruz
so
yes no i i i i've always joked with my
boys you know about playing dumbledore
because i i grew a beard i've been
growing beards facial hair and it's gray
and i'm going gray and you have to you
kind of have to let them know you're
coming so to speak
uh so you just
so you so you hopefully grow into your
years
as an older actor and find work for
yourself as
the wizard or
the sorcerer or
the king
and
you know again you you you try to
find the most interesting
work for yourself and sometimes you have
choices and sometimes you don't have
choices
um
so that's that's where you find me how
you find me
constant work constant doing constant
showing up
when it came to doing something like a
big comic book superhero movie
do you also feel like you still have
some freedom to really make the
character your own in a situation like
that
very much so very much so no again
it's an ensemble piece black adam i mean
you have dwayne who's at the pinnacle of
his fame and fortune and success and
popularity
and he you know is magnificent as black
adam
but you know we are the justice society
and there's four of us and so we became
a strong quartet
of actors
and the writing was
was very good there's just enough beats
you just want three good beats
if you have three good scenes there to
hang your hat and your heart on
then
you know you can make something of your
days
and
for me black adam had that
cinderella
had it in its own specific way
yeah
and those are directors too i mean both
of those directors have very clear
visions with the kind of stories they're
telling and
seem like they really enjoy playing in
the world that they're creating yeah
they do they do uh jama colette sarah
and kay cannon have that uh wonderful
spontaneity which creates a
you know a tangible visceral
feeling electricity on the set that
we're making the movie and it's not set
in stone but these are the parameters
and play the scene out as written and
then just play with it you know and uh
drama on black adam
you know i i could write you know i
could write what about this line what
about that line
and so
he had a very good ear and sensitivity
and likewise k you know she really
she really
is
in every frame of this film her
creativity her interaction with camila
who's a young actress a young woman
with a huge responsibility and
undertaking to play this iconic
character cinderella and
her partnership her working relationship
was was evident
every day was like a sister a mother or
an aunt
you know and
and consequently you have you know you
have that joyfulness and
that immediacy of of of sincerity on the
screen
well i appreciate you talking to me
about it the movie just made me want to
get up and dance so thank you very much
it's okay we'll
stay well and stay happy and
stay strong and
joyful thank you you too